why do pitch meetings exist in the first
place Executives sort of have this issue
where they need lots of stuff to make
their jobs functional
and it is impossible for all of those
ideas to come from one place you can't
just create all of them in the boardroom
and they need outside influence they
need
people who are much more in a creative
mindset to be able to sort of like
Executives look at these things as
problems it's it's you're walking in
saying you know we need X number of
films this year we need 20 films on our
calendar for Q4 and that's all they're
thinking about is much more just like
what are we going to slate when and
where what are we going to program for
this month what are we going to program
for this quarter and they sort of need
um we need a lot of assistance in terms
of like okay what are we going to fill
that with like
I'm really good at you know getting a
deal together I can get the financing
together I can create the opportunity of
this is the movie we're going to make a
lot of the deals I do we're making we're
making movies before the movie exists
before there's a script it's a concept
but I've closed many many deals that are
just you know a big contract with
financial numbers attached to it and all
the titles are to be determined movie
number one number two number three and
it's a package of films that's when we
go out to creative uh Outlets whether
it's production companies development
Executives that we know screenwriters
that we know and it's much more about
like look we need some films here what
do you have or I set up a deal or I'm
sorry I set up a meeting with um a
network or a VOD platform and they want
to know what films we have and so I will
go out to like writers that we work with
a lot and sort of say
I'm meeting with this client you know
what do you have that sort of matches
these types of genres
um and then I'll just take two or three
log lines that they have I'll put them
all together and we'll present them and
see what sticks so to speak and it's
sort of pitching is much more about
taking the creative aspect of filmmaking
or television production or New Media in
general and making it a business case
or taking the business opportunity and
adding that splash of creativity to it
that makes the whole thing stick
together that's sort of the gist of it
but it's really about like just Fielding
information so we can close the deal
well Hollywood always have pitch
meetings absolutely I mean it's it's
every industry has pitch meetings dating
has pitch meetings it's it's
um pitching is really about
taking your opportunity as a person and
sort of just saying like this is what I
can deliver this is what I can make
happen it's um you have to sort of look
if you just sit around and and wait for
the you know
proverbial phone call like it's never
going to come you know it's you do have
to step out there in the world and sort
of create your own opportunities
opportunities never come in clean neat
packages they're usually problems and
companies have problems all the time and
you know it's it's looking at those and
saying
I can find a way in here get my foot in
the door so to speak and solve that
problem and I have the talents to do it
and here's how and why that's all
pitching is it's it's
every industry every scenario in your
life involves a deal of pitching if
you're negotiating anything in your life
if you're negotiating I don't know with
how you want to decorate your house with
your spouse or partner like you're
pitching ideas and you're presenting
Concepts and bringing that to the table
but in terms of Hollywood in terms of
the media business
that's the only way that you're going to
be able to get your ideas heard is by
sort of expressing what you think a
project could be how you think it should
be executed and I think what you should
also be adding to that is that you're
the most important person to deliver it
because of you know whatever reasons you
want to put in there but that's pitching
it's all just what can you deliver what
can you bring to the table how can you
solve other companies or other people's
problems and that's how you get results
well yeah you always hear about that
when let's say if you've ever watched
any entrepreneurial pitches a TV show or
live it's always because someone wanted
to solve a problem they had and if they
created something for the market but how
does someone know what quote-unquote
problems are at a at a production
company or a network that they could be
the one to solve that in truth there's
always a bit of blindness to it
um even on my end where we're meeting
with you know the heads and the
presidents of networks all the time and
even we are a little bit in the dark to
a degree in terms of like what decisions
have they decided Behind Closed
boardroom doors since the last time we
chatted with them
um but
a great way to look at this is uh if you
most of these companies are like massive
publicly traded companies I'm not an MBA
I'm not like some big business Guru I
just kind of like getting movies made
and I'm sort of more creative on the
deal making side not on the story side
um that's sort of how I look at it but
most of these companies whether it's
Netflix AMC networks Discovery Paramount
they're all publicly traded and why
that's important is that anybody
can get on their website and there's
always going to be some tab in there
called investors and if you get on those
and you can look for documents called
10ks or 10 cues and these are required
by law that they publish these big
documents they're insanely long they're
like 300 400 Pages you don't have to
read them all but if you actually skim
through the first couple of pages
there's usually like a letter from the
CEO there's like a breakdown of the
marketplace there's a breakdown of what
they're trying to do in the next year
the next quarter and they list it all
out there like they literally tell you
like a to B this is what we're trying to
do this is what we're trying to get to
these are the problems we have
and this is how we're trying to adapt in
this Marketplace or be competitive so
they list it all out and what's also
good about those is they actually use
their own every company has like their
own internal language that they use how
they like to talk about problems how
they like to speak about projects it's
all listed in there so that's a really
good resource if you're trying to sort
sort of learn what our company's going
for but truth be told if you're newer to
the industry and you're sort of just
starting out
opening those major doors isn't the most
likely uh direct First Step it's usually
going to be smaller companies that feed
into those big ones so it's going to be
smaller distribution companies
smaller production companies and they're
the ones who are actually producing the
core content that will then be delivered
to those bigger players
so if you are looking at more of The
Originals that are popping up on a lot
of these platforms or networks and you
go look at the companies that are
consistently delivering to them those
are the ones to look at but whatever the
big entity problems are it's also going
to Ripple down to the smaller players
too they're sort of like
I call them Like Satellites like they're
sort of satellite companies and they're
always feeding into those big beasts and
so whatever the big beast is having an
issue with the smaller companies will be
too but
that's a great way to find some
interesting opportunities well that's
fascinating I might just do that just to
just to try your example just because so
go to a publicly traded company and look
for investor info and then kind of it'll
be like a PDF or something and see yeah
like the major companies you can
download it like in any conceivable
format and it's um you can you can
usually search through the document so
if you're looking for something very
specific like
certain titles of movies or TV shows or
certain types of platforms that they
might work with like if you looked into
Fox you know 2B is related to Fox Pluto
is related to Paramount so you can get
in there and actually do a bit of
research on the specific platform you're
looking at so yeah